hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
this right here is my
iphone 12 pro max which i love and
this is the brand new galaxy s21
ultra it's the new flagship from samsung
and
it does a lot of things right it's
pretty amazing
so in this video i want to play games on
both of these to see which one is the
gaming
king i guess you would say between these
two phones
i'm going to be playing a couple of the
most popular games call of duty mobile
and
of course gentian impact which has very
high
level graphics now the first thing i
want to do before we begin is match up
the brightness levels
so we have all the way maxed out on the
s21 ultra and a little bit lower
on the iphone 12 pro max because apple
does let you make it
brighter than samsung does and as you
can see
our brightness is matched up on both of
these so i'm going to be starting out
on the iphone 12 pro max playing cod
mobile all right here we are on the
settings on the iphone we've set the
frame rate to max which is 60fps
with very high in the graphics and we
turned on these other settings ragdoll
anti-aliasing real-time shadows and
let's go ahead and
let's get into a match multiplayer let's
do some ranked
team death match now the new iphone does
have these
flat sides and kind of squared off edges
now i thought that would be an issue but
now that i'm holding it and i've been
holding it for
a while the last couple of months it's
not really a problem i feel like it
gives you
i don't know extra grip let's go gross
got him get out of here bro
kill him you see that quadra kill dude
ah come on not bad so far i'm not
noticing any problems
got him got him
yo you guys see that
oh that was that was so funny well that
was good
no issues at all with gameplay perfectly
smooth
just as you'd expect the notch does kind
of suck
we've had this notch forever but i mean
i've been living with it for the last
couple years so you kind of get used to
it kind of like fades away
so far there hasn't been any display
dimming or anything like that so
the speakers are pretty good this year
on the new iphone 12.
i am getting some uh drop frames i think
at least when i die and there's that
ragdoll effect
whoa okay uh what is that
come on the phone feels great there's
only a little bit of drop
frames when i die with the ragdoll
effect but while i'm playing it's
perfectly smooth so i wonder
why that was happening but overall i
kind of like the grip
it's not bad all right now let's go
ahead and switch to the s21
ultra we're here in the settings of cod
mobile now this is very interesting i
can't do
high quality graphics while the frame
rate is set to max
i don't know why but this is extremely
important and let's get into another
ranked match
now i am noticing a couple of things
right off the bat we have that hole
punch which is
barely noticeable compared to the huge
notch so that's a major plus
for the s21 ultra in terms of how
immersive
the display is and i've got to say the
whole display in general i mean it feels
really nice i can definitely tell that
there are
smaller or thinner bezels as well so
that looks really good too but one of
the downsides that i do notice
is how much thicker this phone is like
this thing is
thick compared to the iphone like crazy
thick
and you also have this notch and like my
finger kind of like grubs against it
it's like a little bit annoying
having it right there because the uh
camera bump is massive
gameplay is very smooth though
this guy oh what's up
oh yeah i thought that dude died but he
just laid down
sniper what's up i'm not sure if it's
because this phone is bigger but it's a
little bit more difficult to
hold you know i really don't know what
it is
oh i thought he died he just laid down
oh look at that whoa what was that
weird lag right there at the end one
thing i am noticing is that
because of these rounded edges it does
feel a little bit more
comfortable in your hand because it kind
of wraps around your palm and your
fingers so
i do like that about it and i still get
a good amount of grip
got him look at that get out of here bro
uh nice well that was a quick
round i mean look at that look at that
not bad samsung this is not bad all
right so we're done with cod mobile and
now we have genshin impact we're gonna
be playing it on the iphone
first and i literally just downloaded
this game very recently so
it's been pretty fun so far so let's see
which one does it better
here we are in the graphics settings
i've turned everything up to the max
completely maxed out and as you can see
60fps
is the maximum it's saying the current
perform load is
overclocked so it's going all out
so let's play boom
oh snap
[Music]
these guys are good man
so far at 60fps i'm not
having any issues at all with fps
everything's incredibly smooth so
i'm happy about that explosive
to blow them barrels boom
no this is great i love this this is a
really good
rpg game i've gotta admit
the hype was real
so far i've gotta say absolutely zero
issues
on the iphone it's playing perfectly
60fps i have not noticed any fps
drops at all level nines get out of here
i am starting to feel the back of the
phone get a little bit hot
not too bad i'm just noticing a little
bit of heat there now
dude these guys are tough man
oh you guys see that the display just
dimmed yep
i think due to overheating the display
literally just damned and it is so dark
right now
yep so that heat definitely made it dim
yo who's this
boom it's gonna keep slashing this dude
that was close yeah that brightness
issue
it's not good all right so i'm supposed
to go into this temple but
i'm going to switch to the s21 ultra and
see how it handles it
and see if it also has those display
dimming issues
all right here we are in the s21 ultra
let's go to
the highest we can there you go
60fps this is already feeling not as
smooth
for some reason getting like i don't
know if it's like some weird motion blur
but i mean it's 60fps
however the display is nice and bright
very
bright much brighter than on the iphone
right away i can tell that
boom cryo i'm gonna eat this guy
this guy's like a fire dude frozen
what's up
sick that was cool this is a fun game
i've got to say
fun game let's go
so far so good with the s21 ultra
not only is it playing basically
perfectly smooth
really no issues but we did not get any
screen
dimming and the back of the phone is not
feeling
hot nowhere near as warm as the iphone
was so i think their
vapor chamber cooling or i don't know
whatever they have going on
it's working
i've got to say i'm impressed with the
s21 because it's
it's killing it in this game no dimming
at all great performance all right guys
so i just finished playing over an hour
with the iphone 12 pro max and the
galaxy s21
ultra playing some cod mobile and some
gentian
impact and after that hour let's look at
the battery life
we're looking at 86 on the iphone
89 on the s21 so the battery
life is going to be better on the galaxy
now as far as my conclusion
i've got to say that i loved the s21s
hole punch it doesn't get
in the way nearly as much as the notch
and the rounded design
does feel a little bit more comfortable
in your hand so big plus for that
the display also looks a little bit
nicer and
more immersive now in call of duty
mobile they both played
very very well basically no issues only
a little bit of drop frames
with the ragdoll effect when you die but
other than that
no issues at all so i was very impressed
with both of them
now moving on to gen shin the iphone had
a major overheating issue because the
a14 chip was being pushed
to the limits the back of the phone was
getting hot and eventually
the display dimmed down so that was
pretty bad that's a big issue with the
a14 bionic chip and i really hope
that apple adds a vapor chamber cooling
system
to the next iphone but with the s21
ultra we did not have any issues in
genshin
it played perfectly no display dimming
everything was great
so because of that i've got to give the
galaxy s21
the crown this is the king of gaming
at least between these two phones it
totally smokes the iphone because there
is no
display dimming to worry about and the
performance is also
great so hopefully you guys enjoyed this
gaming video and if you did go ahead and
tap the like button
and click the circle above to subscribe
check out one of those two videos right
over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video